Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast UFO. Das war Stefan T. Und das ist Florentin W. Herzlich willkommen, freut mich ganz herzlich, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt. Und den Intro haben wir heute nicht, oder was? Ach so, sorry, manchmal vergesse ich das. Ja, nee, schönes Intro. Wir bekommen mittlerweile auch mehr Intros, als wir verarbeiten können. Ja. Also entweder wir machen mal so eine gesamte Folge, die ausschließlich aus Intros besteht.
Das finde ich gut. Das sind die Überlebensfolge 200.
Genau. Wirklich einfach
60 Minuten lang Garageband-Loops
oder
wir müssen irgendwie ein Raumzeit-Kontinuum
brechen und irgendwie in die Zukunft reisen
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Was machen wir heute?
Hast du Bock auf...
Ich will mal ein paar an heute. Hast du Bock auf Nico? Ja. Alles klar, dann hören wir jetzt? Ähm, hast du Bock auf ... Ich spiele mal ein paar an heute.
Hast du Bock auf Nico?
Ja.
Alles klar, dann hören wir jetzt das Intro von Nico. Viel Spaß.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zur Ulk-ube. Schön, dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid. Vielen Dank an Nico für dieses fantastische Intro. Mittlerweile ist es bei den Intros fast so, dass eine schöne Sache einfach schlecht wurde, dadurch dass es zu viel ist. Es sind zu viele Intros. Wir müssen mittlerweile pro Folge vier Intros verwenden. Ähnlich wie Weihnachten, habe ich auch gemerkt. Zu viel Weihnachten ist nicht gut? Weihnachten ist einfach mittlerweile ein Punkt, wo es zu viel ist. Normalerweise, also es gibt ja drei Stufen von Weihnachten. Stufe Nummer eins, du freust dich über die Geschenke. Ach so. Gut, Stufe zwei. Dann kommen deine Top drei, gleich kommen meine Top drei Stufen von Weihnachten. Stufe zwei, Mithose. Nein, Stufe zwei, man ärgert sich, dass man selber Geschenke verschenken muss. Ja. Und ich bin mittlerweile schon fast in Stufe drei gekommen. Es ist schon fast wieder eine Arbeit, sich Dinge zu wünschen. Ja. Weil man nicht genau weiß, was man sich wünschen soll, wie ist es dann, wo ist das, man wohnt nicht über den Eltern, wie kriegt man das, wenn man jetzt ein neues Fahrrad will, wie kommt das dann dahin? Ich kriege Geschenke zu Weihnachten, wo ich denke, ihr kennt mich nicht. Ich habe letztes Jahr das Carsten Maschmeyer-Buch geschenkt bekommen, wie man zu Geld kommt. Erstens geht es mir nicht um Geld und zweitens, ich weiß nicht, ob Carsten Maschmeyer derjenige ist, den man fragen sollte, wenn es darum geht, wie man an Geld kommen will. Das fand ich ein Geschenk, was so offenbart hat, dass meine Familie, da hat sich sehr, und ich habe mich sehr, erfremdet einfach. Da ist es nicht mehr, wir kommen vielleicht nicht mehr zusammen. Das ist die Lösung. Vor allem, die wollen einfach sagen, ey, mein lieber Sohn, wir haben keine Altersvorsorge, du musst reich werden. Sieht, mein Lieber. Sieht zu, dafür kannst du deine Moral auch über Bord werfen. Naja, aber das stimmt schon, Reese's Peanut Butter Cups. Ja. Auch so ein Ding, weil die habe ich neulich, in Mexiko gab es die nämlich in klein zum snacken. Ah. In klein zum snacken. Also noch kleine, die sind dann groß so wie ein Eurostück oder sowas? Ja, genau so, aber halt und so hoch wie ein Eurostück, so kleine Dinge halt, so kleine Peanutbutter Cups, so wie geschrumpft. Ist das auch die Währung in Mexiko? Ja, ja, man bezahlt damit. Und die tatsächlich, davon kannst du drei essen und dann kannst du das nicht mehr ertragen. Dann kannst du diesen Geschmack, das ist einfach, das ist zu viel einfach. Das ist einfach reine Erdnussbutter auch einfach. Ja, das hilft nicht, dass darum Schokolade ist.
Irgendwann ist es zu viel.
Ich glaube, noch niemand, meine These ist, niemand hat jemals diese Tüte
Mini-Reeses-Pinder-Butter-Cups
aufgegessen, weil es dann einfach
zu viel ist. Wenn es satt.
Warum gibt es eigentlich dieses Konzept?
Alles in klein. Mir sind
Schokoriegel zu komplex.
Da sind dann viele verschiedene Zutaten drin und länglich. Ich meine, Reese's Pieces macht es genau richtig. Irgendwas, was gut ist, Erdnussbutter, und du packst es einfach mit Schokolade rum und dann noch Nüsse rein. Nee, nee, nee, einfach nur Erdnussbutter. Ah, so eine Karamellschicht. Ist auch keine Schokolade drin drumrum. Ja, einfach nur fucking Erdnussbutter. Warum gibt es nicht zum Beispiel einfach Nutella mit Schokolade drum? Einfach so als Ding, Nutella Pieces. Ja, genau. Das macht Ferrero Rocher falsch, es ist ja einfach Nutella mit Haselnüssen. Ist das wirklich Nutella? Und dann gibt es Nutella to go, diese Riegel, wo aber auch kein Nutella drin ist, sondern auch Nutella mit diesen crunchy Haselnüssen. Wie wäre es denn ein Strohalm, der hinten zu ist und der sich vorne öffnen lässt und der gefüllt ist mit Nutella? Den du so auspressen kannst. Genau, du nimmst den Strohalm, machst den oben auf und saugst ihn einfach aus. Ja, oder so, nee, einfach so wie so ein Monte mit so einem Löffel oben drauf und dann kannst du einfach Nutella auslöffen. Ist Monte eigentlich Nutella? Nein. Ist nicht alles dasselbe einfach mit Nutella zu tun? Ich glaube auch irgendwann, dass alles dasselbe ist auf eine Art. Ich dachte lange, dass das Schwarze von Oreos einfach, wenn man Nutella lange stehen lässt, so mehrere hunderte Jahre, dass man dann abbauen kann. So gepresst einfach, wie so ein Diamant. Ja, das stimmt schon. Dann bleibt Oreo über. Ich glaube, es ist alles das Gleiche. Naja, ich meine irgendwie, schau dir Milch an.
Ja.
Lass Milch lange genug stehen und es wird Käse.
Ja, lass das lange stehen und es wird Schimmel.
Lass das lange stehen und es wird vielleicht wieder eine Kuh.
Und es wird Penicillin.
Ich meine, what the fuck?
Die Erfolgsgeschichte des Jahrhunderts einfach.
Ja, also Milch ist wirklich, ob da irgendwer nochmal gesagt hat, lass es noch ein bisschen stehen, dann wurde es immer schlechteres, immer gefährlichere Schimmel auch. Vor allem als Käse auf den Markt kam, haben sich andere gedacht, okay Leute, jetzt lasse ich aber mal sowas von Apfel stehen. Und dann denkt man sich, jeden Tag steht man auf und denkt sich, ist es jetzt was Neues? Und nein, es ist immer noch ein verschimmeltes, ekelhaftes Stück. Wer ist gestorben, weil er zu gierig war, weil er noch mehr aus Milch herausholen wollte? Das stimmt, er hat es übertrieben. Er hat es übertrieben. Das ist wie ein Aktienkurs, du lässt es einfach, oder ein gutes Ulrike Rotbild, weißt du? Na, wohl, das steigt ja nicht nur durchgängig im Wert, es sei denn, man findet raus, dass es eine Fälschung ist. Ich wäre so froh, dass Ulrike mittlerweile den Wert hat, und das finde ich auch gut, dass er festgelegt ist. Jetzt seid ihr dran. Das stimmt. Wo wir auch schon bei euch wären. Das Bild wurde ja geleakt teilweise. Es gibt Leaks, Pufo-Leaks. Ich habe es noch nicht bestätigt. Ich habe es den Leuten bestätigt, welches der geleakten Bilder das richtige ist, die bei der Szene waren, die gedreht wurde. Ah, der Komparsenaufruf. Der Komparsenaufruf war erfolgreich. 50 Leute von euch waren da und haben fleißig getanzt im Club für die Netflix-Serie. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich hatte vorher, muss man sagen, habe ich mich nicht getraut zu sagen, ich habe sehr viel Gegenwind bekommen von Leuten, unter anderem der Regisseur, der gesagt hat, sind deine Hörer wirklich diejenigen, die wir da im Club haben wollen? Und ich gebe zu, mir sind die Argumente irgendwann ausgegangen, warum es die richtige Entscheidung ist. Aber würdest du sagen, die Leute, die aufgetaucht sind, sind es Leute, mit denen du auf eine Party gehen würdest? Ja. Also, die richtigen Abend durchfallen würdest? Ich würde sagen, ich habe mir Mühe gegeben, jeden mal einmal kennenzulernen und mit jedem einmal zu sprechen. Und das waren wirklich alles durch die Bank ganz, ganz nette Leute. Cool. Fantastische Leute. Deswegen kann ich auch nicht verstehen. Hast du das im Auge? Ne, sind wirklich ganz, ganz toll. Ich finde die Leute mega gut. Ne, es war ganz toll. Und tatsächlich frage ich mich auch, was dann da jetzt in der Telegram-Gruppe los ist, die wir gegründet haben. Ja, wir haben die Telegram-Gruppe geöffnet, von der wir geträumt haben letzte Woche. Hört euch die letzte Folge noch mal an, noch zwei, drei Mal an, wie stolz und mit voller Vorfreude wir gesagt haben. Wir haben eine eigene Gruppe und es wird toll und wir können unsere Hörer ein bisschen besser kennenlernen, aber mittlerweile das ist... Das ist das Anstrengendste, was mir dieses Jahr passiert ist. Das ist auf jeden Fall das Stressigste, wir haben eine Telekom-Gruppe aufgemacht, ich musste wirklich fast körperliche Massnahmen einleiten, um keine Notifications mehr zu bekommen. Ich habe es nicht hinbekommen, weil ich benutze Telekom auch so, um mit anderen Leuten zu schreiben. Ja, das kannst du jetzt vergessen. Und du bist in einem Fenster und schreibst gerade irgendwie mit jemandem. Und oben kommt Bäm, Bäm, Bäm. Und er konstant, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm. Obwohl die Gruppe auf stumm ist. Obwohl die Gruppe auf stumm ist, obwohl du gesagt hast, ich will nichts mehr von euch hören, obwohl du jeden Einzelnen aus der Gruppe angeschrieben hast und gesagt hast, ich will nichts mehr von dir hören. Das haben alle blockiert. Und trotzdem ballert das alles voll und wirklich, mein Handy war komplett durch. Es war auch sofort leer, tatsächlich. Aber es macht schon Spaß. Also ich finde vor allem, wir können das mal reinschreiben. Wir lesen kurz mal rein, was die so schreiben, weil man merkt immer so ein bisschen, das ist so ein bisschen wie wenn die Eltern zu Hause sind, wenn wir im Chat sind, dann hören alle auf zu schreiben. Es wird sofort unangenehm, muss man auch sagen. Es wird total unangenehm und alle meinen so, okay Mama, du kannst jetzt auch wieder gehen, danke schön. Hey Leute, wir nehmen gerade auf. Also hier schreibt, der Podcast-Flo schreibt, ach Herr, der Ringe kannst du sowieso komplett vergessen, tut mir ja nicht weh. Tim K. schreibt, geht mir genauso. Ich war tatsächlich in der Stadt und habe mir eine Hose gekauft. Und ich habe mir kurz überlegt, ja komm, mal privaten Einblick in mein Leben. Ich schreibe den Leuten jetzt, ich kaufe gerade eine Hose, ist es super anstrengend oder nicht, findet ihr auch? Hätte dann vielleicht eine kleine Umfrage gemacht, ja, nein, nicht anstrengend, wow, was hast du für eine Größe? Und ich habe mich nicht getraut, das zu schreiben, weil die gerade ein anderes Thema hatten. Und dann hat jemand gesehen, dass ich oben die ganze Zeit schreibe. Und ich habe aber nicht geschrieben, ich habe einfach nicht weitergeschrieben, ich wollte die Nachricht einfach nicht abschicken, aber ich wollte die nicht unterbrechen. Wer bin ich jetzt in dieser Gruppe aus Fremden plötzlich zu sagen, hey, ich kaufe mir eine Hose, obwohl die gerade darüber diskutieren, ob Einstein seiner Zeit voraus war oder nicht. Annika fragt uns, was ist eure Meinung zu Bademänteln? Gute Frage, Annika. Ich hatte lange einen Bademantel und ich glaube, ich habe früher in meiner Jugend wirklich Samstag und Sonntag komplette Bademantel verbracht. Ich glaube, ich habe aber in einem Anflug von, von Erektionen, ja, die Kordel verloren.
In einem Anflug von Wut vielleicht.
Ich finde, Bademäntel werden erst dann cool, wenn man die Kordel verloren hat.
Weil dann wird man einfach von einem Typen, der gerade aus einer Sauna geht und irgendwie versucht, die Erektion zu verbergen, zu fucking Severus Snape, der einfach seinen riesigen Mantel hinter sich herzieht. Ja, aber mit diesen Laschen noch. Erstmal wie ein flauschiger Severo Snape, mit diesen Laschen, wo offensichtlich die Kordel fehlt. Und du läufst einfach überall hin und hast hinter dir diesen, ich hatte einen großen blauen Bademantel, und überall hinter mir dieser riesige Bademantel, der dann eher zu einem Cape wird, zu einem Cape mit Ärmeln. Ja, zu einem Cape eines Mappen. Und das war großartig. Also ich glaube, diese Capes, dass Snape einfach auch wirklich so, ich glaube, man muss Hogwarts nicht mehr putzen, weil einfach alle Leute mit ihren Mänteln den ganzen Tag da durchziehen und den gesamten Müll. Ja, aber meinst du nicht, dass er in seinen Büros kommt und dann vier Pfandflaschen irgendwie in seinem Mantel hat? Ja, klar. Vier Pfandflaschen und wie heißt die Katze von Hermine? So, Doro. Baut euch. Dorothee. Baut euch euren Gag. Ja, ich glaube, es ist wirklich so, auch der Gemeinschaftsraum von Gryffindor war erstmal an der Tür, ist erstmal so ein Riesenhaufen. So ein Haufen Dreck. Das stimmt schon. Es macht auch einfach deine Seriosität ein bisschen kaputt, wenn du jetzt der dunkle Lord Voldemort bist, durch die Hallen schreitest, aber jemand kann hinter dir auf den Mantel treten und bleibt erstmal stehen stehen. Du bleibst rückerlich stehen, stolperst. Du hast so Kronkorken einfach mit dir mitziehst und dann jede Katze versucht dir so die Kronkorken wegzuschnappen und du einfach, hau ab jetzt, ich will jetzt, hör auf! Lächerlich lange Mäntel. Ich bin pro Bademantel, ich liebe Bademantel tatsächlich, aber ich habe noch nicht dieses Bademantel-Selbstbewusstsein. Nee? Nee. Ich vor allem, ich frage mich, wann es bei mir kommt, und ich weiß, es wird irgendwann kommen, dass ich in so einem, dass ich diese dünnen, diese seidenen Bademittel habe, wo die so fernöstlich gemustert sind, wo man irgendwann sagt, nee, Stefan hat sich in den Westflügel zurückgezogen und ah, nee, da kommt er bereits und dann geht die Musik hoch, irgendwie was Klassisches und dann komme ich die Treppe herunter in diesem Mantel, wo ich nichts runter habe und meine Brustbehaarung schon so rausquirl. Und der ist auch ein bisschen zu kurz und wenn du die Treppe runterkommst und alle gucken von unten, dann müssen wir uns erstmal beschämt wegdrehen. Nee, nee, nee, genau, das ist mir aber egal in dem Moment. Das ist dieses Selbstbewusstsein, den wir haben und ich glaube, das kommt irgendwann, Noch bin ich im Status flauschiger Bademantel. Ja, genau. Das sind eigentlich
die zwei grossen Lebensstadien.
Flauschiger Mantel zu
Salamantel. Aber wenn man alleine wohnt, ist das total geil.
Wenn du in der Dusche warst, Bademantel über und einfach
so vor dem Fernseher. Ja, aber
das Allerwichtigste an einem guten Bademantel,
Taschen. Ja. Muss Taschen haben,
da hast du schön irgendwie noch ein paar Reeses Pieces
drin, die Fernbedienung, dann ist das perfekt.
Ja. Tim K. schreibt, ich komme aus Braunschweig. Gut, danke für diese Information. Dürfen wir Fragen stellen, fragt Friedrich Hose. Ja. Ja, du kannst nicht ja sagen. Ich schreibe ja. Eid Otter schreibt, eventuell nehmen Siegern nackt auf, nur um uns zu provozieren. Ja, da ist schon auf jeden Fall viel los, da gibt es auch schon wahnsinnig viele Insider in der Gruppe. Ich glaube, jetzt ist es fast zu spät. Wir kommen auch nicht mehr rein, es ist einfach schon zu weit. Das ist wie wenn man zu spät auf eine Party kommt und alle irgendwie schon so ihre eigene Sprache entwickelt haben und dann die eigenen Lieder singen. Die Pufopedia hilft so ein bisschen. Die Puffopedia versucht da zu unterstützen.
Ich habe mich wirklich gefühlt wie bei so einer WG-Party, die man geschmissen hat, wo man dann die Kontrolle verloren hat und wo Leute auch angefangen haben, Fremde einzuladen. Dann kommen ganz viele Fremde und wir haben versucht irgendwie mit unseren Schüsseln, mit Chips und Cola eingekauft vorher noch und plötzlich reichen zwei Cola Flaschen für die drei Freunde, die wir haben. Dann sind 80 Leute im Wohnzimmer und man denkt, fuck, fuck, fuck, leg Ulrike Rot weg wieder. Und so war es ein bisschen tatsächlich und wir haben ein bisschen die Kontrolle verloren. Und wir haben noch am Anfang versucht, so ein bisschen die Party zu schmeißen, schön uns immer in die Gruppen reinzustellen, ein bisschen zu sprechen. Jetzt muss ich sagen, haben wir die Wohnung, wir wohnen im Hotel jetzt schon länger. Ja, wir sind ausgezogen. Und wir schauen manchmal rein. Aber ist nicht eine Party dann eigentlich am besten, wenn der Gastgeber gehen kann? Wenn die so ein Selbstläufer geworden ist und man einfach nur so weggeht und zwei Tage später kommt und es hat sich eine eigene Regierung gebildet und irgendwelche Minderheiten werden verbrannt und so. Und dann denkt man sich, okay, jetzt können wir es lassen. Wie Gott. Im Grunde wie Gott. Gott hat uns verlassen. Mein Bruder hat mal eine Party bei uns zu Hause gefeiert und ich war nicht da. Und dann kam ich wieder und dann wurden mir Sachen geklaut. Da haben Partygäste Sachen aus meinem Zimmer geklaut, unter anderem mein Gamecube, ein paar Spiele für den Gamecube und meine Fernbedienung für meinen Fernseher. Kann man ein grösseres Arschloch sein, als eine Fernbedienung zu klauen? Klau Geld von mir aus mein Star Wars, mein Lego-Spaceship. Aber die Fernbedienung, das ist wirklich so ein Tritt ins Gesicht, dass man einfach sagt, ich will einfach, die hat ja keinen Wert. Vor allem, und ich dachte mir, vielleicht klaut er die und sitzt da nachts irgendwie am Haus und schaltet immer einen Kanal um. Oh, Prankster! Prankster! Also so vier Leute brechen ein und drei wollen Geld und der vierte ist so der Comedian in der Gruppe.
Wie interessant. Die Einbrechergruppe hat ja auch so Rollen. Klar. Der Schöne, der Tollpatschige, gut, das hast du jetzt gesagt. Der Rumäne, oft Rumän. Und natürlich auch den Lustigen, der dann sagt, der entscheidet dann, welche Maske man trägt und so. Und übrigens, es gab mal irgendwie so eine Revolution,
irgendwie so einen Bürgerkrieg irgendwo so in irgendeinem Quatschland,
irgendwie Rumänien oder so was.
So ein Spassland.
Irgend so ein Spassland.
Und dann wurde irgendwie der Palast belagert von den Protestierenden.
Palästchen.
Oder halt der Regierungssitz.
Und die standen alle um die Hütte rum.
Und als dann, tatsächlich war dieser Bürgerkrieg schon so lange am Werk,
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Regierungssitz. Und die standen alle um die Hütte rum. Und als dann, tatsächlich war dieser Bürgerkrieg schon so lange am Werk, dass da schon so eine ganze Kultur drum entstanden ist. Und dann viele haben von den Protestanten, von den Protestierenden hatten auch eine Maske von dem Staatsoberhaupt auf. Also wie so eine Maske vom Staatsoberhaupt. Und das Staatsoberhaupt musste irgendwann aus dem Palast flüchten, weil die irgendwie zu nahe gekommen sind.
Und dann ist er geflohen und hatte eine Maske von sich selbst auf.
Also er hatte eine Maske mit seinem eigenen Gesicht auf und ist damit geflohen.
Und das ist genial.
Einfach so, darauf kommt niemand, dass die Person, die du suchst, eine Maske hat von der Person, die du suchst.
Also das ist letztendlich.
Wow, das ist wirklich mega clever. Das ist schlechter Politiker, aber genialer Versteckgeist. Wahnsinn, das ist eine tolle Idee. Und da gibt es Einbrecher auch, die sagen, Moment mal, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie eine Maske haben von Homer Simpson, dann wissen die, oh, die versuchen sich zu verstecken. Aber wenn wir alle Masken von uns selbst tragen, dann denken die, ah, das sind bestimmt andere ausser denen. Fuck, ich kenne zu wenig Prominente, denken die dann erst mal. Fuck, wer ist das? Und ganz Deutschland rätselt, wer ist der? Ist das irgendein Musiker? Ja, schon interessant. Aber wie gemein. Und dann merkt man einfach, wie unsinnig ein Fernseher eigentlich ist. Die Fernbedienung ist das Wichtigste. Aber das ist auch dann so ein Ding. Ich glaube, es hat tatsächlich meinen Fernsehgenuss verstärkt, weil eigentlich Seppen ja macht das Fernseherlebnis eigentlich kaputt. So genau wie heute. Ich glaube, ich schaue mir kein Video mehr länger als zehn Sekunden an. Ich schaue mir so Meme-Compilations an, zehn Minuten Meme-Compilation und nach dem eineinhalb Memes mache ich aus. Und dann denke
ich mir, was hast du erwartet?
Memes sind genau, ich gebe dir, was
du denkst, dass du bekommst. Du weißt schon,
was du kriegst. Ja, vor allem, ich habe dann auch
neulich mal einfach ein Video nicht geschaut, weil die Werbung
davor zu lang war. Und dann klickst du noch mal
auf ein anderes Video und dann hast du nur zehn Sekunden
Werbung und das ist okay. Und dann dachte ich mir
wirklich, ja, das Video, der Inhalt kann
jetzt nichts dafür, aber ich klicke dich jetzt weg, weil die Werbung davor eine Minute lang war und die werde ich mir nicht angucken. Das ist im Internet so, die Opportunitätskosten sind immer zu gross. Ich stelle immer einfach anderes Video. Und deswegen glaube ich, mit dem Fernseher, wo du selber manuell umschalten musst, ist eigentlich besser, weil du länger an einem Programm dranbleibst und mehr eine Chance gibst. Ja, das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ich habe tatsächlich mittlerweile, ich habe so ein YouTube-Video gesehen von einem YouTuber, der sein Kleingeld eingewechselt hat und der hat dann irgendwie sein Kleingeld gewogen und hat dann gesagt, okay, jetzt gehe ich los und hat er sich halt gefilmt zur Bank und so und das habe ich mir komplett angeschaut, aber der hatte zwei Kilo, glaube ich, ungefähr zwei Kilo Kleingeld und hat dann das abgegeben in der Bank und das waren 200 Euro ungefähr. Und dann habe ich mal mein Kleingeld gewogen. Und ich will jetzt nicht genau sagen, wie viel es waren, aber es war deutlich mehr als zwei Kilo. Als zwei Kilo. Und ich dachte mir, holy shit, habe ich viel Kleingeld? Und dann dachte ich mir, okay. Aber wo fängt dann wieder die Kleingeld an? Das ist ja auch nur eine Definitionsfrage. Na, ich komme jeden Tag, wenn ich nach Hause komme, tue ich das gesamte Kleingeld aus meinem Geldbeutel, was kleiner ist als ein Euro, in den Eimer. Okay, 50 Cent mache ich schon nicht. 50 Cent und drunter kommen in den Eimer. Wahnsinn, 50 Cent kommt bei mir in die Schublade für den Lieferheld-Fudora-Typen. Ah, da kommen bei mir zwei Euro Stücke rein. 50 Cent Trinkergisch. Nein, drei mal 50 Cent. Oder mal ein Euro oder 50 Cent. Aber immer 1,50. Hast du eine Ahnung, wie viel Kilo der insgesamt schon mit sich rumtragen musste, nur weil du ihm drei 50-Cent-Stücke gegeben hast? Ich habe von Leuten, das hat mir schon mal das Thema, da haben Leute gesagt, nein, Stefan, mach dir keine Gedanken, weil ich gebe auch manchmal gerne sehr viele 20-Cent-Stücke. Wenn die 50-Cent-Stücke ausgegangen sind, gebe ich einfach dem so einen Batzen 20-Cent-Stücke, 10 20-Cent-Stücke. Und dann hast du gesagt, du hast mich als arroganten Arsch bezeichnet. Ja. Und tatsächlich haben viele Leute gesagt, das wäre voll okay, wenn man das macht. Welche Münze hat das höchste Wert-Gewicht-Verhältnis? Das kannst du dich formulieren. Die ist sehr kompliziert gestellt. Ich weiß, worauf du hinaus willst. 20 Cent, oder? Also ein 20-Cent-Stück wiegt mehr als zwei 10-Cent-Stücke. Ach so. Nee, ich glaube, bei einem Euro ... Können wir das Intro noch mal hören? Bei einem Euro glätzt glaube ich nicht auf, weil das 50-Cent-Stück ist ja schon grösser als das Ein-Euro-Stück. Und es ist die Hälfte wert. Das heißt, die Frage auf deine Antwort ist, nein, nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Aber dann habe ich mir gedacht, weil ich bin ja jetzt über Weihnachten nicht da, und dann dachte ich mir,
okay, ich wohne jetzt nicht in so einer so teuren Gegend, vielleicht wird mir eingebrochen.
Über Weihnachten ist, glaube ich, kann man gut
machen. Das mit Abstand
wertvollste, was ich habe,
ist mein Kleingeld.
Mein Kleingeldeimer.
Mein Kleimer. Und dann dachte ich mir,
also ich habe... Wie praktisch das wäre, wenn
er weg wäre. Ja, aber auf der
anderen Seite wissen
Einbrecher, wie viel Wert
Kleingeld ist. Ja, ich glaube nur, das ist zu schwer. Ach so. Ja, das ist zu schwer, aber wenn die wüssten, was... Das ist verräterisch beim Rennen. Das stimmt. Die Polizei muss nur so einmal in die Stadt horchen und hört so... Da hinten ist er! Aber ist das nicht auch so, hat man das nicht gemacht im Mittelalter, wenn sich Leute an Kindern vergangen haben? Hat man denen auch so eine Klappe hinten dran, hinten schön an die Jacke, so eine kleine Klappe und immer wenn die, das war doch so. Das stimmt. Einen an der Klappe haben. Unter anderem zum Beispiel auch der Henker. Der Henker, wenn du den Henker berührt hast, dann war das schlecht für dich tatsächlich, dann war das gesellschaftlich schlecht für dich, dann kamst du in die Hölle. Wer den Henker berührt, ist im sozialen Status gesunken. Wer ihn nur berührt, selbst unabsichtlich. Aber wer dann die Prinzessin berührt, der steigt wieder. Dann geht's wieder hoch. Das heißt, der Henker musste ganz grelle Kleidung tragen und hatte auch in manchen Orten, musste er so eine Klingel tragen, dass Leute von ihm Abstand halten können, damit sie ihn auf gar keinen Fall beenden. Aber hat der Henke auch manchmal so ... Nee, das ist halt ... Das ist die ...
Ha, ha, ha halt und dann die okay, schnappt ihn! Das ist mal eine lustige Komödie-Serie. Henker Schmidt. So einfach und das ist Aber kann der Henker, was denn, der Henker kann ja Scheiss machen und niemand kann ihn verhaften, weil niemand ihn anfassen will. Wie hat der Henker eine Freundin? Der Henker bei Tinder.
Diesen Beschreibungstest bei Tinder werde ich mal sehen vom Henker.
Ja, ist tatsächlich, aber ist... Ich freue mich sehr, euch kennenzulernen. Ihr könnt mich halt nicht berühren. Niemals.
Ja, du machst ja jetzt Scherze und du lachst dich gerade kaputt über das Thema.
Ich glaube, ich habe mich kaputt.
Ist aber ein interessantes Thema, weil es ist tatsächlich nicht so leicht.
Und in der Regel musst du dann natürlich mit anderen Leuten dann sich verheiraten,
die auch irgendwie ihre Ehre verloren haben.
Zum Beispiel die Witwen von den Leuten, die er umgebracht hat. Weil die waren eh raus, weil der Mann irgendwie Mörder war oder was auch immer, dann ist gleich die ganze Familie unten durch. Und dann sagt der Henker so nach der Hinrichtung so, Frau Berlinger, eigentlich haben Sie heute noch was vor? Und die, mein Mann! Nein? War das ein Nein? Also ganz interessantes Thema. Also ich glaube, da steckt noch viel. Da steckt noch viel, da könnte man glaube ich so eine ulkige Miniserie draus machen, so zehn Folgen. Und dann welche, wie schwer es ist mit dem zu daten. Du, nächstes Jahr. Lass uns mal was machen. So ein urdeutsches Thema. Ich glaube, man müsste mal wirklich, also jetzt so diese neuen Netflix-Serien, das regt mich auf, dass sie dann alle schon wieder so hypermoderne Cyberthemen und so. Warum nicht mal so einen urdeutschen Stoff? Nein, Netflix bietet ja auch sehr viele neue, tolle Sachen an. Zum Beispiel eine Serie über die Teutonen. Ja, aber na ja, gut. Ein paar Serien über germanische Völker zum Beispiel. Ja, aber das ist ja dann alles so hollywoodisiert. Oh nein, das ist ganz toll. Da hast du so große Schlachten. Und das ist alles historisch inkorrekt. Weil ich alles schon sagen wollte, ist nämlich, so was wie Game of Thrones kann man ja in den USA gar nicht gut drehen. Die haben nicht so viele Burgen. Die haben keine Burgen. Wir in Deutschland haben so unfassbar viele Burgen, die teilweise noch so toll erhalten sind. So was müsste man hier total gut drehen können eigentlich. Also ich glaube, man kann hier richtig gut für relativ überschaubares Geld eine unbeschreiblich gute Mittelalter-Serie drehen können. Ja, ich glaube auch, dass viele davon, gerade so Kroatien oder so, wo viel Game of Thrones gedreht wird, ich glaube, dass sie auch stark davon profitieren, dass viele Filme da gedreht werden. Ja, aber die Verlierer, aber die Verlierer sind sehr viel gleich in den reisen. Aber ich glaube, in Deutschland könnte eine nicht unbedingt große High-Consent-Serie trotzdem eine sehr, sehr tolle Serie. Lass uns das auch schreiben. Henker Fritz. Henker Fritz. Das ist jetzt sehr speziell. Und vor allem der Gag ist auch irgendwann vorbei mit dem Anfassen. Ich will nicht die fünfte Staffel Henker Fritz sehen, ehrlich gesagt. Meinst du nicht? Wer fasst ihn dieses Mal nicht an? Der hat meinen Hund berührt. Ist das jetzt auch? Ist das noch lustig? Lachen wir schon in Folge zwei. Ich mag es in der Serie nicht, dass die immer in die Kamera gucken und fragen, ist das jetzt lustig? Lach gerade. Bitte schreibt uns. Wir wissen gerade nicht, wir haben ganz schlechte Werte beim Screening bekommen. Vor allem nach so einer Dramaserie hätte ich jetzt richtig Bock einfach auf knallhart Comedy. Ja, Mittelalter-Comedy. Einfach nur Comedy, aber in die Fresse Comedy. Schön, manchmal ist das Bild verkehrt rum, so eine Comedy. Ja. Weil diese ganzen Regeln nerven, einfach mal alle Regeln über Bord werfen. Wie wär's denn mit so einem Typen, okay, Mittelalter, super krasser Aberglaube und der sagt sich einfach so ein bisschen, so ein Hochstapler, der einfach eine eigene Religion gründet, der einfach sagt, Leute, fuck it, ich denke, was auch. So schwer kann das doch nicht sein. Und der gründet eine eigene Religion und dann faked der so Wunder und so und dann schliessen sich dem immer mehr an und irgendwann ist der total krasse Typ mit irgendeiner totalen Quatschreligion, die sich ausgedacht hat. Weißt du was, meinetwegen nehmen wir schon das, meinetwegen nehmen wir einfach
die erste Idee, die da kamen. Hörst du zu, Netflix!
Tele 5, 5,
5, 5?
War das denn Tele 5,
die Tele 5-Höhle, in die du kurz reingeschrien hast?
Ist sie nicht in der Höhle?
Also wenn ein Sender
irgendwie so eine Batman-artige Höhle hat,
dann Tele 5 auf jeden Fall.
Ja, oder Dreisat. Wo man da einfach so eine Stange runterrutschen muss. Nicht Arte, die in ihrem poschen Schloss. Oh, Elfenbeinturm. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht, wenn man einfach in einer Höhle. Warum nehmen wir nie in einer Höhle? Warum ist die Podcast-Ufosentrale nicht in einer Höhle? Gibt es denn noch viele Höhlen? Klar gibt es Höhlen. Ich habe Angst vor Höhlen. Ja? Ja, stimmst du, nein. Das stimmt, das kann passieren.
Früher war ich tatsächlich häufig in Höhlen als Kind, weil bei uns gab es ein paar Höhlen, die Dächchenhöhle, glaube ich, also so im Isalon herum gibt es eine Menge, Menge so Kram. Und da war ich häufig in Höhlen und das war irgendwie, dachte ich, ja, es gibt sehr, ich dachte, das wäre ein grosses Ding in der Welt, Hlen. Man wird langsam darauf vorbereitet, so, falls man mal in einer Höhle ist. Man lernt so viel über Höhlen. Ich weiß so viel über Kalk, ich weiß so viel über Stalagmieten, Stalaktiten. Die spielen danach keine Rolle mehr. Ich war seitdem nie wieder in einer Höhle. Ja, man legt sich halt sehr fest mit Höhlenwissen. Also wenn man sich dazu entscheidet, den Weg zu gehen, Höhlenwissen zu akquirieren, legt man seinen zukünftigen Weg schon recht stark fest. Ich behaupte, es ist so eine Blase, die sich selber im Leben erhält. Und die dann noch sagen, ja, kommt her, wir machen Führungen durch Höhlen. Wobei, und bei Lehrern, die mal sagen, dann machen das nur, weil das schon immer gemacht wurde. Die stellen man nicht in Frage, was das überhaupt bringen soll, dass Kinder in die Höhle, durch eine Höhle gehen. Das ist gefährlich. Eigentlich könnte man es abschaffen. Finde ich auch. Ich glaube, es gibt viele Dinge auf der Welt, die im Endeffekt niemand vermissen würde. Die einfach nur da sind, weil sie da sind. Die gemacht werden, weil die immer schon so gemacht wurden. Ich möchte, das finde ich eine lustige Frage, die mich wirklich interessiert. Welches Ding am Flugzeug ist einfach nur dran, weil es immer schon dran war.
Und man könnte ohne das Ding fliegen.
Das ist wie so ein Blinddarm.
Ja, aber angenommen, gibt es ein Blinddarm, eine Milz, braucht man eine Milz, gibt es die Mandeln, was sind die Mandeln des Flugzeugs, die man einfach so rausnehmen kann. Weil ich habe jetzt mal gehört, dass die 737 zum Beispiel und auch die A320 oder ich glaube damals war es noch 19, keine Ahnung. Das sind in etwa die Dinge, die seit den 80ern gebaut werden. Da hat sich nicht viel verändert, so ein bisschen was drumrum und hier hat was die Aerodynamik besser gemacht, da vorne haben sie irgendwas elektrisch gemacht, aber im Prinzip ist das der gleiche Körper noch und der gleiche Entwurf. Was ist da noch dran? Einfach weil es beim ersten Mal schon mitgeflogen ist und es hat funktioniert.
Das würde mich wirklich mal interessieren. Braucht man das alles? Es kann sein, so diese kleinen Flügel, die da hinten nochmal dran sind. Ja, irgendwie sowas. Braucht man die oder sehen die einfach nur cool aus? Die haben vorne so einen Stab, der runtergeht. Ich glaube vor allem, dass gerade Flugreisen so ein extrem emotionales Thema sind, dass wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel, du hättest das Flugzeug, das ist 40 Prozent effizienter, super krass, aber es sieht ganz anders aus. Es sieht aus wie so ein Baumkuchen, so eine große hohe Röhre mit einem Loch drin. Die Leute würden damit nicht fliegen wollen, weil die zu viel Angst haben. Es gibt zu viele irrationale Ängste rund ums Fliegen, dass die Fluggesellschaft pleite gehen würde. Es gibt auch viele rationale Ängste,
weil alles, was ein bisschen anders aussah,
ist oft, also Stichwort Zeppelin.
Stichwort
Konkord. Ja, aber jetzt kommt er wieder mit dem Zeppelin.
Stichwort Konkord. Keine Folge ohne
Hindenburg, ey. Zeppelin,
die Tage waren wieder in Zeppelin
über Köln. Ich kann darüber immer nur lachen.
Lächerlich. Ich finde es wirklich lächerlich.
Und es war der Original Zeppelin. Und dann habe ich überlegt, warum ist das so lächerlich? Und es ist die die Grösse-Nutzen-Relation. Ja, absolut. Es muss so viel passieren. Dafür, dass diese kleine Kapsel mit zwei Leuten drin, manchmal sind auch sechs drin, manchmal ist ein kleines Restaurant drin, okay. Aber am Ende vielleicht ist es ein Riesengefährt, was ganz langsam fünf Leute transportiert. Ich glaube aber, dass in dem Bollen noch was drin ist. Also ich habe mal einen Detective-Con-Film gesehen, Film sogar, nicht eine Folge. Das ist gezeichnet, Flutti. Und ich glaube, da war in dem, aber da ist ja alles voller Helium oder Wasserstoff oder sowas. Es gibt zwei, das ist nämlich der Unterschied. Der Original Zeppelin, ich weiß nicht, ob es der Original war, 50, 50, schon geht es hier mal all in. Der Original Zeppelin hat innen drin nichts, nur am Rand. Wie nichts? Einfach Wacken. Naja, du kannst atmen da drin, aber du hast dann so Ballons, wo das dann drin ist, dieses Gedöns.
Also in dem Ballon sind nochmal Ballons.
Ich glaube schon, oder in der Außenwand
in so zumindest. Und dann gibt es aber noch
den einen, wo
drin alles Helium ist. Und Dynamit,
die Sie gesagt haben. Genau. Dynamit
fliegt gut. Nee, das ist, beim ersten Mal
hat jemand eine Dynamitstange drin vergessen und seitdem
dachten die, ja, komm, wir lassen es da drin einfach.
Was soll schon passieren? Diese 600 Liter Benzin, müssen die hier rumschwappen? Ja, passt schon, ja. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich so ein Baumkuchenflugzeug durchsetzen würde, weil die Leute einfach Angst haben. Und ich glaube, dass alles, was nicht aussieht wie ein Flugzeug, wird auch nicht als Flugzeug wahrgenommen. Oder ist das nicht schon so? Wir wissen es doch nicht. Vielleicht sind neue Flugzeuge, sehen eigentlich anders aus, man hat nur die Verpackung eines alten Flugzeuges drüber gestülpt. Ach so, verstehe, das ist wie so eine aufblasbare Hülle. Ja, eigentlich gibt es die Flügel, die sind einfach nur, die Flügel sind aus Gummi. Ja, ja. Aber man hat sie einfach drüber gestülpt, weil man die nicht mehr bräuchte. Ich meine, es gibt ja sowas wie dieser Tarnkappenbomber, der dann wirklich nur so ein Dreieck ist oder so. Das geht ja, ist ja alles möglich. Aber ich glaube, für Personenverkehr wäre das nicht nötig, möglich, weil Leute sagen, da steige ich nicht aus. Dann krümelt der Donut überall hin und dann nein, nein, nein. Und dann drehen alle um und dann gehen die weg von der Startbahn. Menschen sind so lächerlich. Und dann sagen die, aber Leute, ihr seid dreimal so schnell da. Nö. Nein, nö, fahr ich mit Fahrrad. Ja, aber dann beschweren, dass es immer noch zu langsam ist. Aber nicht mit dem Baumkuchen fahren. Das sind Menschen. Ich hasse ihn. Ich sag bewusst fahren, weil es ein Luftschiff wäre. Es braucht mehr Pioniergeist. Es braucht mehr Leute, die sagen, fuck it, dann geh ich halt drauf, aber wir müssen jetzt diesen fucking Baumkuchen endlich mal in die Luft bringen. Fucking fucking Baumkuchen. Ich setze mich jetzt mal auf den Flügel. Aber vor allem, wie viele Dinge sind eigentlich schon wieder gestrichen worden, weil einfach zufälligerweise der erste Flug schief ging? Weil so Flugzeug jede zehntausendste Fahrt stürzt ab, sagen wir mal. Jede zehntausendste Flug stürzt ab. Oder sagen wir mal, jeder Hunderttausendste von mir aus. Von mir aus jeder millionste Flug. Schon sehr sicher. Oh Gott, mit seinem was ist was Flugzeugen buchendertastet. Aber jeder zweite Zeppelin-Flug. Ja, aber es kann ja sein, dass der Baumkuchen auch jeder Zehntausendste Flug abstürzt, aber halt dummerweise war es halt gerade der Erste. Und dann haben alle gesagt, fuck it, ich steige nie wieder da ein. Und dann wurde das komplette Projekt gecancelt, obwohl es eigentlich gar nicht nötig gewesen wäre. Ja, genau, diese ersten Flugmaschinen, die man manchmal sieht, von Da Vinci zum Beispiel, der so ganz doll seine Arme bewegt hat und dann so Flügel sich ganz schnell auf und ab bewegt haben. Wie so eine große Schraube, die sich so einfach in die Luft schraubt. Bei Vögeln funktioniert es ja, weil wenn die nach oben gehen zum Beispiel, lassen die Luft durch. Und dann, wenn die Federn wieder nach unten schlagen, dann doch, doch, doch auf jeden Fall. Nein, das stimmt nicht. Mit nicht. Nein, stopp, da möchte ich jetzt mal ganz kurz einhaken. Ich kann mich nicht viel an meinem Biologieunterricht erinnern. Aber interessant fand ich immer die Punkte im Unterricht, wo der Lehrer gesagt hat, uns wurde das noch so und so beigebracht, aber jetzt bringe ich es euch anders bei. Im Sinne von, während meines Lebens hat die Wissenschaft solche Fortschritte gemacht, dass sie sich im Lehrplan niederschlagen. Und unser Biologie-Lehrer hat gesagt, uns wurde damals noch erklärt, dass Vögel jüdischer Abstammung sind. Aber das haben wir auch nicht hinterfragt. Oft beginnen gefährliche Ausufrungen nach diesem Satz. Uns wurde das noch so
beigebracht. Aber in den Gaskammern
wurden niemals Gasrückstände gefunden.
Der meinte, uns hätte
man das so erklärt, als würden die
fliegen, indem sie, wie wenn man jetzt eine
Handfläche macht, und wenn die die Flügel
hochnehmen, machen die die Hand auf. Ja, so wurde es mir erklärt.
Und dann beim Runtergehen machen sie die Hand zu.
Und er hat gesagt, so ist es aber nicht, sondern die
sind wie Flugzeuge, dass die Flügel halt so sind, die Tragflächen und die dann halt so seitlich hochziehen. Und wie starten die denn dann zum Beispiel? Die springen vom Baum. Nee, so eine Taube kann ja auch vom Kölner Domplatz abheben. Ja, ein Flugzeug kann auch vom Boden abheben. Ja, aber die Taube läuft ja erst nicht, bis sie nicht erreicht hat. Ja, das Flugzeug kann ja die Flügel nicht bewegen. Die Taube kann das... Die Taube läuft nicht wie wildlos. Und man sagt so, man muss immer ausweichen, weil schon wieder eine Taube Steilerlaubnis bekommen hat. Das funktioniert so nicht. Tauben können ja die Flügel schlagen und dann gehen sie ja steil hoch, senkrecht. Es gab bestimmt auch mal Vögel, die so gestartet sind. Ich meine, die Evolution hat alles mal gemacht. Wie ist es wild? Hat einfach mal wild, mach mal einfach mal. Nee, ich glaube schon, dass es ein bisschen noch so ist. Aber natürlich klar, in der Luft fliegt ein Vogel ja auch wie ein Flugzeug. Ein Flugzeug ist ja auch quasi angelehnt an das Modell der Natur. Aber naja, wie dem auch sei. Und ich glaube, die Da Vinci-Idee war ja auch, dass er gesagt hat, man bewegt die Arme ganz schön hoch und runter, hat aber diese ganze Federn-Sache nicht bedacht. Und der Typ, der da drin sass, ist immer ganz doll hoch und runter geschlödert worden und dann abgestürzt. Da gibt es so Videos von. Und ich finde auch, also das hätte ja auch funktionieren können. Aber stell dir mal vor, sowas durchfunktioniert. Das Video ist so lustig. Alle voller Erwartungen. Und er stirbt nicht nur, sondern er stirbt auf die lächerlichste Weise, auf die man sterben kann. Wild durchgeschüttelt werden, während man von dem Berg runterfällt. Ja, oder dieser Einrad-Typ, der so dreht und dann oben diese Avatar-Tiere, die es auch im Avatar-Film gibt, wo oben so eine Spirale, so eine Segelspirale drauf ist, die sich so dreht und sich so im Wind hochschrauben will und der Typ dreht sich die ganze Zeit und stirbt. Das sind einfach lächerliche Tode. Ey, damit wir heute fliegen dürfen, mussten eine ganze Menge Leute so dumm aussehen. Dumme Tode sterben. Das kann man auch wirklich mal honorieren. Ja. Ich finde, es bräuchte einen neuen Feiertag für Leute, die für Scheissideen sterben müssen. Nee, die für gute Ideen in einer Scheissidee erst mal gestorben sind. Ja, genau. Die einfach mal die schlechten Ideen rausschaffen, damit die guten Ideen bleiben. Ja. Da bräuchts einfach mal so einen Tag. Oh, da sind so viele lächerlichen Tod gestorben. Das ist wirklich traurig. Dreht sich einfach ganz schnell in der Luft und stirbt da. Oder andere Theorie, das effizienteste Flugzeug würde einfach eins zu eins aussehen wie ein Storch. Wirklich exakt so. Storch. Aber die Leute, die Ingenieure machen das nicht, weil die sich denken, das würde einfach so fucking albern aussehen, wenn wirklich das Flugzeug aussehen würde wie ein großer Storch. Und halt im Schnabel sitzt halt dann der Pilot und im Bauch ist die Kantine.
Und die sagen, das können wir nicht machen, das sieht einfach zu dumm aus.
Weil Leute, die Ingenieure sind, haben ja als Kind Lego gebaut und coole Modellflugzeuge, die wollen ja auch, dass es cooler aussieht.
Und wenn die dann sagen, unsere Tests ergeben, also dann zum Computer und dann drückt man auf den Knopf und der Computer rechnet den und dann sieht es einfach aus wie so ein Frosch und du sagst, Leute, das machen wir nicht, auf keinen Fall machen wir das. Ja, aber so ist es ein bisschen bei manchen Zügen, die ja einfach vorne aussehen wie so ein Kopf an einer Schlange. Ist jetzt cool geworden. Aber das ist so, der Schinkansen hat so eine Schnabelform von so einem Vogel, der so die ins Wasser rein stösst und der hat so eine bestimmte Schnabelform.
Ja genau, aber wie cool, die haben auch auf den Knopf gerückt, und dann kam was cooles raus, und alle so, what, geil, so machen wir es. Ja, aber vor allem, wenn jetzt sagt, und wie sähe der Mittelteil von dem Zug aus, zack, Blobfisch, biep, ah, scheiße. Ja, aber das wird deswegen auch ein wahnsinnig guten Sketch. Oder auch mal so, wo man ein Sketchkanal hat. Oder auch mal so Panzer oder so. Ich meine, der ist super effizient, aber er sieht halt einfach aus wie eine Kröte. Und niemand nimmt dich ernst, einfach so. Mit großen Augen vor allem, wo so zwei Leute hinter sitzen und sagen, ja. Und mit so Schulterzucken, wie was schwarzen fällt. Ey, macht euch nicht lustig, sonst töten wir euch. Es ist wahnsinnig gefährlich und effizient, was wir gerade haben. Sieht aber lächerlich aus. Niemand nimmt sie ernst. Warum habt ihr dann gekröten Kostüme an? Ja, effizient. Ich meine jetzt mal ganz unter uns. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Aliens uns besuchen, ist hoch. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit aber, dass sowohl die Aliens als auch die Aliens-Raumschiffe unfassbar albern aussehen, ist auch extrem.
Die haben das Stadium überschritten, wir trauen uns nicht.
Die sind so in dem Freddie-Mercury-Status von wegen,
wir ziehen jetzt einfach an, was wir wollen,
wir fliegen in den Dingen, die wir wollen.
Die sind im Seidenbademantel der Raumschiffe schon.
Ich glaube, es gibt ja so ganz viele Filme,
so was ist, wenn die Aliens kommen und dann Krieg. Ich glaube, die erste Reaktion auf Aliens wäre einfach mal lachen. Einfach mal ein bisschen wie Scheißen guckst, siehst du denn aus? Und Aliens so, äh, hallo, Leute. Ich finde es bei Arrival aber auch schon lustig. Ein toller Film, den ich sehr realistisch wahrnehme, aber ich finde diese muschelartigen Dinger, wo man sich fragt, und die schweben da einfach rum, und niemand weiss, wo sie sind, ich habe so ein bisschen lustig einfach, wie so eine grosse Ohr, was man hingesetzt hat, und dann machen sie erstmal nichts und gucken mal, was passiert. Aber Arrival ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil da sehen die Aliens ja einfach aus wie Oktopoden. Und du denkst ja einfach, okay, alle...
Die klassischen Oktopode.
Aliens, die halt nicht ... Du willst halt gerade für so einen ernsten Film, dass du die Aliens ernst nehmen kannst. Und wenn die aussehen würden wie Gary oder halt irgendwie Greedo, dann würden alle sagen, was, das sieht total bescheuert aus. Und deswegen sagst du, ja, die sehen halt aus wie Oktopie. So, und dann passt das schon. Ja. Im Grunde ist es eigentlich feige, aber auch nachvollziehbar. Ich bin mal mit einem, ich habe mal einen Kumpel besucht, der in Irland ein Auslandsjahr gemacht hat. Und der hat mit einem Amerikaner zusammen gewohnt. Und das, was ich am meisten daran mit verbinde und mich daran erinnere, ist, dass der Typ einfach, dem war, wir sind dann so über die Klippen gelaufen, steiniges Gelände, und er hat einfach gesagt, this boots, my boots may be ugly as hell, but they are dry und so.
Er meinte, er hatte so krasse, hässliche Schuhe. Selbst das Wasser hat gesagt, Leute, Leute, Leute.
Alle, das ist er mir nur geschaut, die waren so hässlich.
Aber er hatte am Ende trockene Füsse und bequem.
Wir haben alle Blasen, weil es einfach so bubebergig war und ich habe meine Nike-Schuhen, hat gar nicht funktioniert, aber er, und da seitdem denke ich mir auch, klar, er ist wie eine Art weiterentwickelte Spezies, dem das egal ist. Und ich glaube, so sind auch Aliens, die haben dann einfach so North Face Sachen an, weil die sehen dann halt scheiße aus.
So Tatonka-Jacken, so Windjacken.
Tiger. Und man sagt einfach, oh Leute, wir warten seit hunderttausend Jahren auf euch und jetzt haben die so warme Anoraks. Ja, jetzt haben die Ohren schoner Leute und die so was denn? So, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep We may be ugly as hell, but it works.
But we are dry, it works.
Wirklich einfach Aliens, die nicht ernst genommen.
Ist auch eine interessante Serie.
Gibt es eine Comedy-Serie? Ja gut, Mass Attacks und sowas.
Aber das ist halt dann ...
Rick and Morty, das ist ja auch der Humor so ein bisschen.
Aber Rick and Morty ist ja von Anfang an schon alles Science Fiction eigentlich.
Als du jetzt eine normale Welt erzählst, wo einfach Aliens kommen. Und dann gibt es so einen Journalisten, der sagt, ich schreibe jetzt hier was. Tatsächlich war das ja mal, ich würde mal, kann man mal Insider-Sachen sagen, ich wurde mal für ein Buch angefragt und das war meine erste Idee. Meine Idee war, ich will jetzt kein Sachbuch schreiben, sondern einfach Aliens bevölkern die Erde. und ich glaube, als dich Leute angefragt haben, Buch zu schreiben, sind die auch davon ausgegangen,
dass sie kein Sachbuch schreiben, sondern einfach Aliens bevölkern die Erde. Ja, ich glaube, als dich Leute angefragt haben, ein Buch zu schreiben, sind die auch davon ausgegangen, dass du kein Sachbuch schreibst. Dass du nicht Erdölbohrungen im 16. Jahrhundert schreibst, sondern irgendwie was, ein fetzigen Knallerroman. Ich erkläre jetzt meinen Feminismus. Frauen, setzt euch mal hin, so heißt das Buch, von Stefan Thiesel. Hört mal jetzt alle zu, bitte Frauen.
Frauen hergehört, das neue Buch von Stefan Thiesel.
Das denken Frauen wirklich.
In Klammern glaube ich.
Was ich eher meinte, war Kurzgeschichten.
Also das ist ja so der Klassiker, dass man Leute, die auf Twitter mal drei Sachen rausgehauen haben, die tausend Likes haben, dass man die dann mal fragt, habt ihr nicht Bock, irgendwie so ein Kurzgeschichtenbuch rauszubringen und so. Und da dachte ich mir, nee, einfach knallhart in Science Fiction gehen. So was habe ich... Ernst oder was? Oder lustig? Nee, schon lustig. Ungewollt lustig. Wegen der vielen Rechtschreibführer auch. Meine Idee war folgende. Dann erkläre ich jetzt einfach alles,, mir auch scheißegal. Es kommen Raumschiffe auf die Erde. Die Erde hat irgendeinen wissenschaftlichen Durchbruch erlangt. Meinetwegen haben die irgendwas ausgerechnet. Die nächste Nachkommastelle von Pi, keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls sowas, dass die Galaxis sagt, okay, die Erde ist bereit. Dann kommen ganz viele Raumschiffe und jetzt folgen wir dem einen Alien, der in Deutschland das Postleitzahlgebiet, weiß nicht, fünf bekommt.
Und da, da wurde er sein Leben lang das und deren Job. Die werden darauf vorbereitet, wie es ist, andere Planeten in die Galaxis reinzuholen. Also die Erde ist jetzt klug genug, um in so einem intergalaktischen Club da zu sein. Und man folgt diesem Alien, wie es so VHS-ähnliche Kurse gibt,
für Leute, die jetzt ausgewählt wurden, um das Werem ihrer Nachbarschaft oder ihrer Siedlung oder so zu zeigen. Und deswegen dachte ich, wäre doch lustig, einem Alien zu folgen, weil so eine Reisegruppe aus Menschen hat, die dann auch wiederum für ihr Gebiet verantwortlich sind, und mit dem reist es dann durch die ganze Galaxis und zeigt denen, wie es läuft. Aber funktioniert das denn? Muss nicht eher der Protagonist jemand, ein Mensch sein, der dann in dem Kurs sitzt? Ja, es war auch erst so ein Mensch. Und er hat sich dann verliebt in eine andere Kursvernehmerin. Und dann ging die Geschichte komplett nur noch über Ferrero-Küsschen und unangenehme SMS. Dann muss es Feminismus-Sache. Aber naja. Das ist doch eine gute Idee. Danke. Jetzt guckt er so traurig. Nee, ich will kein Buch schreiben. Ich habe jetzt mal in so ein Fussballspiel reingesappt. Und ich finde es immer interessant, wie die darauf reagieren, wenn die was falsch machen. Halt irgendwie so daneben schießen oder irgendwie sowas. Dann ärgern die sich immer so energetisch, weil das sind ja Hochleistungssportler. Und die haben dann auch immer so die Schießenden und dann so, oh Mensch oh, verdammt noch mal, beim nächsten Mal klappt. Verdorrig noch eins. Ja, genau. Aber ich fände es viel lustiger, wenn die einfach wirklich traurig wären, wenn ich einfach daneben schiess und dann wirklich so, oh, und dann wirklich an die anderen müssen dann kommen und so, jetzt komm, komm schon, hey, oder hier, komm schon, hier, und dann geht es wieder los. Also, ich habe noch nie während des Spiels jemanden traurig gesehen, mit authentischen Reaktionen gesehen. Wer wirklich so daneben schießt und dann so, oh Mann! Vor allem, man ist ja auch nie, also wie bist du in einem normalen Büroumfeld, bei deiner Arbeit? Unerträglich. Aber du bist ja auch nicht so, dass du dich aufregst. Also, das sind ja gespielte Emotionen, die die haben. Meinst du? Ja, aber die denken schon die Kamera mit, glaube ich. Die denken schon ihren Close-up in den ganzen Wohnzimmern in Deutschland mit. Ich glaube, dass sie ja neben ihrer sportlichen Ausbildung ja auch eine mentale Ausbildung haben. Und den wird man wahrscheinlich gesagt haben, wenn du daneben schießt, dann irgendwie versuch da die Motivation, okay, beim nächsten Mal kriege ich es hinzuziehen. Lustigerweise hat mir mein Tennistrainer das Gegenteil erzählt. Er hat gesagt, dass beim Tennis-Leuten ein hochpsychologischer Sport ist, weil du halt, keine Ahnung warum, brauche ich gar nicht, ich versuche mich da jetzt, ich habe keine Ahnung warum, aber weil du da auf die Leine gestellt bist und so und keine Nuancen, schon sehr viel entscheiden können am Tennis. Und da wird Leuten gesagt, dass sie sich sehr über Siege freuen sollen, über gewonnene Ballwechsel und nicht aufregen sollen, gar nicht aufregen sollen über verlorene Ballwechsel. Weil das nicht runterzieht in so eine Abwärtsspirale.
Aber es gibt doch manchmal, die dann den Schläger
auf den Boden hauen und so. Und hast du davon schon mal
einen Gewinn sehen? Nee.
Okay, du hast recht. Habe ich wohl recht gehabt.
Habe ich wohl schon wieder mal recht gehabt.
Es ist ja auch
interessant zu sehen. Ich kann mich noch
erinnern, als ich als Kind, ich habe als Kind glaube ich
mehr Fußball geschaut als heute,
dass Leute auch, dass Spieler innerhalb der Mannschaft sich gegenseitig auch wirklich beschimpft haben. Da schießt jemand Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, ich mehr Fussball geschaut als heute, dass Leute auch, dass
Spieler innerhalb der Mannschaft sich gegenseitig
auch wirklich beschimpft haben. So, da schießt jemand
daneben und dann sagt, hey du
Spacko, was schießt denn daneben?
Aber heute gibt es immer nur den Daumen,
wenn jemand vollkommen ins Nirvana schießt,
dann motiviert man sich dagegen.
Früher war es eher, ja du Vollidiot, wo schießt du denn hin?
Warum laufen Menschen anders?
Also wenn du die Fussballspiele von den 60ern, 70ern anguckst, warum laufen die anders? Und warum jubeln die, ich mach's mal kurz vor für dich, die jubeln immer so. Wie so ein Hampelmann, der die Arme, der beide Arme gleichzeitig hochsteigt. Alle haben so gejubelt. Mittlerweile ist es nicht mehr so. Mittlerweile geht sehr diverse Jubel. Aber früher hat man immer so, und die sind anders gelaufen, immer mit den kurzen Höschen, die sind immer so weit.
Ich glaube, es liegt an den Hosen. Ich glaube, die waren einfach. Kann schon sein. Ich glaube, das bestimmt schon viel. Du läufst ja auch anders mit anderen Hosen. Unpopular Opinion, aber ich glaube, man kann sehr schnell sehr gut über Fussball reden.
Ja?
Ja. Ich bin neulich an so einem Kiosk hergeelaufen, wo ich nur mit den Gesprächsfetzen gehört habe, ah, Mönchengladbach ist diese Saison auch richtig gut. Die haben diese zwei Achter, die sich auch mal fallen lassen. Ich dachte mir so, oh Gott, du hast gar keine Ahnung. Nee, die haben zwei Achter. Oder sehr viel Ahnung. Zweimal die Achter auf dem Rücken oder das? Nee, die Position des Achters gibt es ja. Neuners zum Beispiel, klassischer Stürmer, der Einser, der klassische Torwart, Sechser, klassischer Vorstopper.
Ich denke, das kann man nicht ganz gut einfach drauf schaffen, diesen Sprech.
Ich glaube, ich behaupte, wir könnten, wenn wir jetzt eine Woche lang die Begriffe lernen, uns komplett durchcheaten.
Bis hin zu Experten bei Sky. Meinst du? Ja. Es ist nur ein reines Gedroppe von irgendwelchen Namen und Begriffen. Es geht ja eigentlich immer darum, dass du... Den Ballenstorch. Also die Frage ist, du kannst ja Leute nicht callen eigentlich, wenn sie Unsinn erzählen. Das habe ich noch nie erlebt, dass jemand sagt, wie meinst du das jetzt, sich fallen lassen? Ja, da sagt niemand, äh, ich, äh. Ja, halt, die laufen halt wieder zurück, wie zurück, ja, halt, halt nach hinten. Das ist noch nie passiert. Also, dabei bleibt es ja dann eigentlich. Das heißt, wenn du eigentlich nur noch ausgefallenere Begriffe benutzt als der andere, der würde ja nie sagen, du hast gerade Schleife gesagt. Was meinst du mit Schleife? Fussball ist doch kein komplexes Spiel. Ich habe das Gefühl, weil es so beliebt ist, hat man dann da irgendwann eine abendfüllende Veranstaltung daraus gemacht. Wenn es so ein Länderspiel ist, geht die Berichterstattung um 20.15 Uhr los, dann ist irgendwann um 20.45 Uhr der Anstoss und dann kommt die Halbzeit und so weiter und dann geht die Berichterstattung bis 23 Uhr. Und ich glaube, das Spiel ist ja nicht komplex. Da stehen Elfmann auf dem Feld und die müssen den Ball, den sie nur mit dem Fuss berühren dürfen, ins andere Tor schicken. Na, aber was der Helio da macht mit den Feldern und so. Aber dann, weil es so beliebt wurde, dachte man, okay, wir machen das bis 23 Uhr, wir strecken das einfach. Und ich glaube, da ist so eine Bullshit-Spirale in das Laufen, dass man dachte, okay, wir müssen jetzt einfach so lange darüber reden, was reden wir über diesen Sport? Und dann ist so eine erdachte Komplexität erstanden. Aber eigentlich, wenn man mal runterbricht, was Experten sagen, ist, ja, die haben den Ball nicht ins Tor bekommen. Also, klar kannst du Chancenverwertung sagen, weil es besser klingt, aber die haben den Ball nicht ins Tor geschossen. Ja, es ist weder ins Tor gerollt noch geflogen. Ist nicht passiert. Es ist nicht vorgekommen. Das kann man einfach, also ich glaube, man kann sämtliche Aussagen von Experten immer darauf runterbrechen. Denen ist es heute gut gelungen, den Ball ins Tor zu schießen, den anderen ist es nicht so gut gelungen. Also du behauptest, auch wenn der beliebteste Sport in Deutschland wäre, wer kann am härtesten mit einem Hammer gegen die Wand hauen, selbst dann würden in der Halbzeitpause Leute fachsimpeln. Ich glaube, wenn es Arm drücken.
Ne, sagen wir, wenn es Schere, Stein, Papier zur berühmtesten Sportart gebracht hätte, gäbe es auch dreistündige Abendveranstaltungen, in der gefachsimpelt würde. Es gibt ja wirklich Schere, Stein, Papier Turniere. Schaut mal auf YouTube, es gibt wirklich Turniere, wo ich bis heute nicht weiß, ist es einfach ein Insiderwitz, der einfach zu weit gegangen ist? Oder meinen die das wirklich ernst?
Weil ich meine, es ist ja wirklich denkbar, dass man durch irgendwie Psychologie oder dann irgendwie. wo ich bis heute nicht weiß, ist es einfach ein Insider-Witz, der einfach zu weit gegangen ist?
Oder meinen die das wirklich ernst?
Weil ich meine, es ist ja wirklich denkbar,
dass man durch irgendwie Psychologie oder dann irgendwie Tricks, keine Ahnung, irgendwie
das hinkriegt schon. Also häufiger als
der Durchschnitt zu gewinnen, das ist ja immer ein Glückskombinand.
Aber wie beim Poker wird ja der, selbst wenn es um Glück
geht, wird der bessere Spieler langfristig
häufiger gewinnen. Ob das möglich ist oder
ob das einfach so ein Spassding ist?
Weil es muss ja jemand gewinnen und dann heißt es, oh,
der hat letztes Jahr gewonnen, uiuiui.
Es gibt ein paar Tricks, wie man das leicht gewinnen kann,
wenn man es nicht häufig spielt.
Weil es so rein
psychologisch weiß man, was Leute
zuerst machen und so. Und Männer machen
das eine eher, Frauen das andere eher
und so was. Tatsächlich gibt es das.
Statistiken. Also du würdest sagen, dass Männer und Frauen unterschiedlich denken? Ja, ich kann nochmal die Frau erklären. Lest das nach in seinem neuen Rohroman. Naja, ich glaube, da wird es wer für Gegenwind hagel, habe ich das Gefühl gerade schon. Aber ich glaube, wenn das Fussball nicht so komplex ist, wie es so getan wird. Ich glaube, es gibt viel komplexere Sportarten. Football zum Beispiel ist meiner Meinung nach die viel komplexere Sportart. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich kann es nicht sagen. Ich sehe manchmal nur Billard und denke mir, ach komm. Ja, da gibt es keine Experten, die sagen, oh, da hat er jetzt aber nicht so häufig die Kugel ins Loch getroffen. Weil im Billard gibt es ja manchmal Züge, wo der eine den Tisch abräumt und der andere sitzt auf dem Stuhl.
Du meinst Snooker.
Nee, ich meine Billard. Wirklich Billard.
Wo es sein kann, dass der eine, der anfängt, einfach alles abräumt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Der einfach beim ersten Stoss schon was reinkriegt und dann einfach eine gucken und nach der anderen reinzieht.
Du meinst Billard.
Richtig. Und dann schaltet er immer wieder auf den anderen, der auf dem Stuhl sitzt und er guckt dann so.
Was soll ich jetzt groß gucken? Aber der ärgert sich nicht so wie der Fussballer. Ja, das ist eher so ein In-sich-Gehen, so ein, hätte ich nicht doch was anderes lernen sollen als Billiard. Ich meine, ich weiß nicht, auch so Experte. Ich meine, es gibt ja in unterschiedlichen Sportarten unterschiedlich gute Experten, zum Beispiel Tobias Ascher von Rocket Beans, der auch bei Rocket Beans zu sehen ist. Superkrasser Typ, hat Bücher über Fussball geschrieben, aber zum Glück kennt er sich gut mit Fussball aus. Wenn der sich so gut mit Billard auskennen würde, würde es niemand interessieren, würde niemand sein Buch kaufen. Willst du mal, du und Tobias Escher mal zusammen einen Podcast, eine Stunde, wo die Rede mal über Fussball ist, der erklärt dir mal Fussball. Ja, also es ist sehr arrogant, aber ich glaube, wenn man sich ein bisschen, wenn man sich im Monat intensiv mit Fußball beschäftigt, kann man zumindest so tun. Vielleicht entlarven das dann Leute, aber ich glaube, der durchschnittliche Biergartenbesucher denkt, ja, die Jungs haben recht, die lassen sich, aber die Achter lassen sich aber ganz schön fallen. Ich glaube schon, dass es geht. Das stimmt. Ich habe immer in Sandalenfussball gespielt.
Ja, das war vielleicht der Zeh.
Die besten Schuhe, weil die hatten eine ganz
harte Unterfläche.
Und damit konnte man gut schießen,
obwohl die Zehen frei lagen.
Oh Gott, das ist doch bestimmt mega weh,
wenn du mit der Picke triffst.
Ja.
Oh, dann ist das Zeh ab. Ich habe übrigens zum Thema Sportlichkeit ein paar Sachen mitgebracht. wenn du mit der Picke triffst. Ja. Das stimmt.
Ich habe übrigens zum Thema Sportlichkeit ein paar Sachen mitgebracht.
Ich sehe schon, du hast die ganze Zeit da vorbereitet.
Ich habe zufällig
alle meine alten Jugendsachen dabei.
Meine Mutter hat mir das mitgegeben. Meine Eltern ziehen jetzt aus ihrem
Haus aus. Und ich habe alles
bekommen, was meine Mutter nicht wegschmeissen wollte.
Zum Beispiel mein Schnorchel-Brivet.
Was ist ein Schnorchel-Brivet? Anscheinend habe ich zwei Schnorchelkurse gemacht, A und B, und die habe ich bestanden. Ich habe bestanden, zehn Meter Streckentauchen ohne Startsprung, bestanden am 21.05. Zehn Meter Streckentauchen ohne Startung? und zwar vom Prüfer JR. 15 Sekunden Zeit tauchen. Bestanden am 14.05. Das habe ich hingekriegt. Also das ist meine sportliche Laufbahn, habe ich alles geschafft. Geil. Ja, mega gut. Zeig mal bitte. Du hast vor allem einen Fahrradwimpel bekommen. Ich habe sogar den Ehrenwimpel bekommen von der Polizei Bayern, bayerische Polizei. Oh, Bescheidigung über die Teilnahme am Wahlkurs. Ja, ich habe einen Wahlkurs belegt. Was weißt du denn so über Wade? Es sind Säugetiere. Ja, Herrn Florentin Will, nein, Herr Florentin Will hat in der Oberstufe mit grossem Einsatz und Erfolg am Wahlkurs darstellendes Spiel teilgenommen. Mit viel Engagement verkörperte er seine Rollen in mehreren Aufführungen und bereicherte zudem mit seinem Interesse für das Schauspielen und seinem Theaterwissen den Gruppenprozess. Bei den Proben steht es positiv. Auch half er bei organisatorischen Aufgaben mit. Okay. Er Rolle bekommen. Darüber hinaus hat er im Schuljahr 2019 im Arbeitskreis Video und Film mitgearbeitet. Das ist ein Leerzeichen zu viel. W. Hopfner. 2019? 2019. Du wirst, glaube ich, nächstes Jahr einen Wahlkurs machen. Zeig mal die Urkunden alle. Das ist ja fantastisch. Gibt es auch hier noch Fotos von dir? Will Florentin, Berchtesgaden. Bei euch sieht das alles anders aus. Bei euch sieht alles aus wie so ein Bieraufkleber, wie so ein Bieretikett. Guck mal wie das aussieht, guck mal wie das aussieht. Das ist der Bayerische Alpenverein, ja? Ja gut, aber hier auch so die Urkunden, das sind alles so offiziell aus, wie auf so alten Papyrus. Bei uns hat man einfach so einen Wisch bekommen, so einfach auf das Papier, was gerade da war. Und manchmal war man verrückt und war was anderes drauf. Hier, die Skilehrerin Simone hat mir eine Urkunde gegeben, in der Leistungsklasse B habe ich anscheinend einen Skikurs bestanden. Und das ist den zweiten Platz gemacht. Ja? In Kurs zwei. So, wen haben wir denn hier noch? Oh, da haben sogar Leute hinten auf dem... Echt, Gward, Gefahre! Echt, Gward, Gefahre? Ja, da habe ich anscheinend einen Skikurs gemacht und meine Mitschüler haben hinten drauf unterschrieben auf der Urkunde. Was steht da? Stefan Abräumer, Max, Ausrufezeichen. Jemand hat ein Hakenkreuz drauf gemalt, nicht der, sondern der Max, Auflösung, Franzl, die haben weirde Namen in Bayern, Ting, Julian, Korbi, Silvia, David mit W, gut, man weiß nicht, ob welcher Name ist oder ob er sich verschrieben hat. Rafsan. Das klingt wie so ein Cast aus einer schlumpfartigen Serie mit Rafsan. Wir alle kennen ihn noch. Nein, niemand hat den Film niemals gesehen. Mit Rafsan, Corby und Stefan Abräumer. Die Abenteuer ist. Ich kann es nicht lesen. Aber Stefan Abräumer, wäre das was für dich, für deine nächste Lebenskrise? Stefan der Abräumer, hey, das sind keine Lebenskrisen, das sind Phasen, mit denen ich meine Unglückseligkeit überspiele. Ting. So, das Zeugnis der allgemeinen Hochschulreife. Hier haben wir es doch. Oh, keine guten Noten sehe ich da schon vorblitzen. Da sehe ich schon schlechte Noten vorblitzen. Hör auf jetzt. Ausreichend in Geschichte. Ja, na ja. Ja, du, warum? Das interessiert mich wirklich. Ist das mein Abi-Zeugnis, oder was? Doch, die allgemeine Hochschulreife, das ist ein Abi-Zeugnis. Wahnsinn, du warst nicht so gut. Nee. Warum warst du nicht so gut? Du bist so ein cleverer Mensch.
Lateinmangelhaft?
Das haben wir ja schon mal angelogen. Ich war tatsächlich der Einzige in der Klasse, der kein Latinum bekommen hat.
Da hast du mich aber schon mal angelogen, glaube ich.
Nee, das habe ich dir immer genauso erklärt.
Ich habe nämlich gesagt, dass man eine Latinum bekommen hat, wenn man mit einer Vier oder besser abgelegt hat.
Und ich war der Einzige, der mit einer Fünf abgelegt hat.
Was war deine Abinote? Zwei Sechs. Das stimmt, das steht hier auch. Ich wollte nur mal gucken, ob du lügst. Wahnsinn. Aber was war das Thema meiner Facharbeit? Das steht hier nicht. Doch, das müsste eigentlich auch stehen. Auch keine AGs oder so. Das ist einfach eine traurige, leere Seite. Keine AGs. Keine AG teilgenommen, trauersmähne. Hing immer unter der Treppe bei der Cafeteria rum, ansonsten nichts. Im Raucherbereich hat aber nicht geraucht. Wo steht das denn hier mit der ... Ich dachte, das stimme da auch drauf. Hier oben. Wirtschaft und Recht. Hier oben. Oh, Facharbeit in Englisch. Thema The Aspects Alive in Scotland as depicted in Three Short Stories. Ergebnis zwölf, immerhin zwölf. Ja, aber in der Toilzeit, kann man eigentlich wegschmeissen sowas, oder? Soll man sowas aufheben, seine Schnorchelurkunde von Kinderjahren? Nee, das Schnorchel Brevet, glaubst du nicht mehr, glaube ich. Die Hochschulreihe Brevet. Weiß es nicht Brevier? Ich weiß nicht, was Brevet überhaupt ist, das noch nie um Leben gehört. Es heißt B-R-E-V-E-T steht da drauf, Brevet. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, dass Bayern ein ganz anderes Land ist. Das stimmt schon, das kann man ja nicht. Es ist ganz woanders. Auch das Zeugnis sieht anders aus. In Sütterlin. Meins war mit Areal halt einfach. Areal 11 und dann durchgeballert. Bei euch war immer was anderes. Ja. Anderes Land. Sehr schön. Nächste Woche sind wir in Köln. Und ich bin sehr aufgeregt. wir haben nämlich einen Riesen-Live-Auftritt hier in Köln im Tanzbrunnen. Übrigens ist nächste Woche in Köln und falls ihr sagt, wow, was, die kann man auch live sehen, diese unfassbar interessanten Gespräche möchte ich live erfahren, dann könnt ihr das noch tun. Es gibt nämlich noch Karten für die Tour, aber nur noch in Wien. Ja. Nur noch in Wien. Also wenn ihr sagt, oh Weihnachten, ich habe keine Ahnung, was soll ich schenken, was soll ich meinen Wiener Freunden schenken. Wiener sind ja oft einfach sehr wohlhabend, verwöhnte, arrogante Wichser, das kann man ruhig immer so sagen. Ja, und denen kann man ja am besten dann eigentlich nochmal ein Ticket zur Pufo-Liveshow geben. Ansonsten freuen wir uns auf alle, die nächste Woche in Köln kommen. Ja, kommt in unsere Telegram-Gruppe, die ist fantastisch. Und ich denke, da braucht man ein paar Leute, die noch mal ein bisschen durchgreifen. Hier schreibt jemand Kevin R Top fünf Kinderserien, fünf die Dinos, vier SpongeBob, drei Gummibärenbande, zwei typisch Andy und eins diesens große Pause. Gummibärenbande, kann man Colin dazuzählen? Ich weiß es nicht. SpongeBob auf jeden Fall auf Platz eins.
Ja.
Gut, danke schön, die Rekungruppe.
Und rein, weiterhin viel Spaß.
Ich bin echt gespannt, das ist unsere größte Halle in Köln.
Ist die größte Halle, ja. Krass.
Da würde ich mir gerne ein paar Experimente machen.
Mir klingen tausend Menschen.
Ich will einen richtig schlechten Gag machen. Da mache ich mir nicht so viele Gedanken, dass das passieren wird. Aber ganz schlechten Gag und dann will ich mal ... Stille. Ja, weil niemand bombt mehr vor tausend Leuten. Also Leute, die tausend Leute spielen, haben sie das erarbeitet. Ja, das stimmt. Bei uns ist es irgendwie gerade so ein bisschen passiert. Aber so tausend Leute spielen Bill Burr, spielen vor tausend Leuten. Wir haben ja auch Bill Burr in der gleichen Location gesehen. Ja, und der bombt, so jemand bombt ja nicht mehr. Ich will einfach nur das peinliche Schweigen über einen nichtwitzenden Gag von tausend Leuten hören. Apropos, jetzt nochmal viel Spaß mit dem Intro von Nico. Mit dem Outro. Vielen Dank, mit dem Outro. Weil es funktioniert auch ganz toll, das Outro. Ich finde, es passt sogar noch besser als Outro. Hört jetzt rein, ansonsten macht's gut.
Ansonsten macht's gut.
Haut rein, bis dann.
Ciao.
Wehm ab.